like  not very nice  and uh wesley under the minute  i mean  vessel in just playing very powerfully  in this armageddon game  queen to f1  that's it another nice move  threatening rook takes e1 rook f6  getting ready to meet rock taxi one with  rook f8 yep but this is the clincher  lethal pin yeah i mean you can't even go  rook to f8  because rook takes bishop just kills it  so this is why king f2 was played but  white is just scrambling to stay alive  rook b takes e1 wins and if queen takes  that's his last trick unless he resides  directly  if queen takes what he's got to say then  rook takes the still rook of eight  but instead  like has queen b2 check  up clearing the b7 square for the king